moi j'ai dit United now maintenant moi
j'ai besoin de ça les gars moi j'ai
besoin de cette unité de cette
fraternité les gars 1 2 3 et on monte
tous en repos 1 2 3
ça c'est pour ça
il y a beaucoup de gens ils font pipi à
côté ils font exprès de faire caca à
côté donc du coup on n'est pas valorisé
en fait dans notre travail
je sais pas je me pose la question tous
les jours il y a évidemment cette
fameuse séquence dont on me parle
régulièrement ce qui s'appelle la
séquence du caca boudin c'est à dire que
je pars dans la nature parce que j'ai
des besoins pressants à évacuer et j'ai
des enfants il y a des enfants qui ont
fabriqué une très longue pelle et qui me
suivent et qui glisse l'appel au moment
où
mon bébé
[Applaudissements]
pendant 8 heures personne ou presque ne
lui adressera la parole il récupère la
matière et normalement n'importe qui
quand tu fais ça dans la nature il se
retourne pour voir
et quand il voit rien là il y a quelque
chose de métaphysique qui se passe aide
à démouler le flan
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça mérite un cours de biologie la
psilocybine substance psychoactive
contenue dans les champignons magiques
et la MDMA ou ecstasy pour les intimes
sont toutes de connus comme drogue
récréatives mais de plus en plus
d'études suggèrent que ces deux
substances peuvent produire des
améliorations rafices chez les personnes
souffrant de dépression ou de stress
post-traumatique êtes-vous un homme
pressé
[Musique]
ce que je suis un homme pressé
pas là apparemment
américain qui apparaît dans un
documentaire sur la question
australienne à tester pour vous
ok plus sérieusement dans The cranberry
time Scott Edwards directeur du
mindmency Project par le de plus de 50 %
de taux de rémission après un traitement
de courte durée c'est ici en Isère dans
le petit village de Moret caché dans la
montagne que cette autre peau abritait
une véritable usine à cannabis des
trafiquants d'origine albanaise faisait
pousser plus de 4000 pieds d'herbe dans
cette ancienne carrosserie à l'intérieur
une installation sophistiquée filmée ici
par un policier le local de 700 mètres
carrés est totalement hermétique une
puissante centrale électrique alimentée
des lampes UV 24 heures sur 24 pour
optimiser la croissance de l'herbe
quelle abréviation de rastafari et
couramment utilisé rasta
[Musique]
enfermés depuis deux mois avec
interdiction de sortir comme nous le
raconte l'avocate de l'un d'eux il était
chargé notamment de surveiller les
plantations et d'arroser les plantes
cannabis bah voilà tout simplement pour
permettre le développement de la culture
moi mon client m'expliquait qu'il était
en réalité enfermé dans le dans le local
toute la journée
avocat qui annonçait que vous portez
plainte avec Marc Menant vous portez
plaint contre Marine tondeuillier
secrétaire nationale Europe Écologie Les
Verts pour quelle raison
alors parce que Marine tombe de lier
avait expliqué que cnews propagait une
idéologie néo-nazie ça va monter tout
seul je vais tourner la paume de main
sur l'extérieur et je vais aller
jusqu'en haut
et je vais aller jusqu'en haut mais
Estelle on va commencer
à ça de maman et dans mon émission face
à l'info Marc Menant avait fait une
sortie qui nous avait tous beaucoup ému
il était au bord des larmes en
expliquant que son père avait été
déporté et qui sait ce que c'est que
c'est que justement le nazisme et qui on
est loin de l'idéologie nazisme ou
néonazi la première ministre hier qui
dit on va prendre notre temps pour poser
le diagnostic vous trouvez que c'est si
on parle vraiment sérieusement mais
c'est une honte si on se dit vraiment
les choses c'est une honte on va poser
le diagnostic ça fait 40 ans qui a fait
de la politique mais il servent à quoi
elle fait quoi
je mets un peu d'eau sur un truc
et puis voilà
c'est très efficace nous sommes réunis
autour de Sweety pour l'accompagner et
pour vous apporter un peu de réconfort
Sweety avait un caractère bien affirmé
battant
elle a affronté cette dernière semaine
avec courage
au nom de toute l'équipe de crime
animaux fin je vous présente toute notre
compassion Jacques pourquoi vous avez ce
que je voulais très rapidement faire un
clin d'oeil affectif à Alain Delon et le
plan des Siciliens je suis bouleversé de
ce qui arrive à l'un de l'autre nous
connaissons qui est un mec bien est-ce
qu'il lui arrive actuellement je veux
dire bon ça va s'arranger et je voulais
par le Clan des Siciliens lui faire un
petit clin d'œil cette cérémonie
touchante
permet à Morgane et assez de sœurs de
surmonter plus facilement leur deuil
un dernier regard
[Musique]
parce que vous avez des actions à
prendre peut-être pas du tout je vais
rendre je vais saluer sur sa tombe ça va
pas faire marrer votre téléspectateurs
mais moi ça me fait marrer c'est
l'essentiel lire je vais rendre hommage
à Alphonse Capone voilà non plus
c'est jamais ça Suzanne évidemment vous
l'avez pas fait exprès si si bien sûr
une enquête a été ouverte aujourd'hui à
l'encontre de la chanteuse
Izia enquête pour provocation publique à
commettre un crime ou un délit et ce
après un concert jeudi soir à
Beaulieu-sur-Mer dans les
Alpes-Maritimes durant lequel la fille
de Jacques Higelin a tenu sur scène des
propos très virulents envers Emmanuel
Macron qu'elle appelait entre autres à
lyncher je cite comme une pinata avec
des battes et des clous au bout les
gendarmes ont tenté d'interpeller
l'artiste à l'issue du concert sans y
parvenir elle aurait été exfiltré dans
son bus
quoi des nouvelles tout augmente la
lumière l'essence les pâtes le riz
bientôt on va travailler tu sais pas
pour faire beau pour la gloire bientôt
on mangera plus
faudra choisir entre se chauffer se
nourrir se loger
[Musique]